we're gonna start again with the weather
because nearly 90 million Americans are
now in the grip of dangerous cold as the
polar vortex spreads across more of the
country at least nine deaths are
connected to the historic winter blast
that's causing major disruption across
the Midwest and Northeast temperatures
across the Upper Midwest feel like the
negative 50s with the wind chill for a
second day the US postal service is
suspending mail delivery in many areas
six states are affected energy companies
in Minnesota and Michigan are asked
asking customers including major
automakers to cut their use of natural
gas DeMarco Morgan is in Minneapolis
hopefully warm with how people are
coping DeMarco good morning John good
morning to you the cold weather has
pretty much brought life to a standstill
across the Midwest everything from
schools to air travel businesses even
utilities as you said are being affected
the relentless polar vortex is
delivering a third day of dangerous snow
and sub-zero cold from the Midwest to
Boston whiteout conditions caused havoc
on the road and some places drop it up
to 12 inches of snow you can't see
anything it's like a giant cotton balls
falling at your car and Wyomissing
Pennsylvania at least 27 vehicles were
involved in a massive crash critically
injuring at least two people the cold
once again proved to deadly a student at
the University of Iowa was found dead
outside of a university building where
temperatures dipped to negative 22
degrees
officials say weather was a factor the
freezin is also disrupting air travel
this week more than 2,000 flights have
already been canceled for today hundreds
are delayed and utilities are dealing
with a dilemma of high demand in
Minnesota and Michigan energy companies
are asking millions of customers to
conserve natural gas to avoid stressing
the system
Michigan's consumers Energy Company
asked the Big Three automakers to
suspend operations at their Michigan
plants all complied including GM which
shuttered 11 plants across the state at
Chicago's Trinity United Church there
you go sir the homeless are offered a
warm place to stay this is the type of
cold where people not only get
hypothermia frostbite but that people's
lie
are at stake according to the National
Weather Service just 10 minutes outside
and negative 32 windchill will give you
frostbite but Midwest farmers don't have
much of a choice they have to keep
working somehow you get the job done
this 800 acre dairy farm in Goodhue
Minnesota has been in Kenneth shrimp's
family for three generations he says the
key to working outdoors in this extreme
cold is finding ways to adapt you warm
up you go outside and you get cold you
just go warm up and go back you're in
and out a lot when it's all said and
done this system could cost the u.s.
billions of dollars similar to the one
that happened back in 2014 when it cost
the US economy five billion dollars so
everything comes with a price tag
hopefully things will start heating up
DiMarco we don't want to upset and mrs.
Morgan your mom there I know she was
worried yesterday I don't need her
calling our producer saying get my son
inside DeMarco get inside
thank you I think she's proud I'm
staying warm